news and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
to be clear this doesn't stop with
donald trump
tonight on politics now president trump
impeached again
the votes from nevada's delegation and
where things go in the senate
a nevada assemblyman caught up in a
campaign finance
scandal what we know about the police
investigation into alex assefa
i believe that we should really focus on
a plan let's get some sort of plan in
place
and then continue working on distance
learning
and is it back to school or back to the
computer the ccsd school board vote on
trying to put children back in the
classroom
[Music]
from 8 news now this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langler donald trump has been
impeached for
a second time now it's up to the senate
to determine
if the president actually gets convicted
the house of representatives voted
232-197 to impeach president trump
for inciting an insurrection of the u.s
capitol 10 republicans joined the
democrats
most of the gop though argued for unity
in the president's defense even if some
admitted that he bears some
responsibility
a vote to impeach will further fan the
flames
of partisan division the terrorists who
stormed this building
plan to hang the vice president kill the
speaker and topple our government
democrats argued even with less than a
week left in president trump's term
a senate conviction would likely bar him
from ever running for president
again so here's how nevada's
congressional delegation voted on
impeachment
democrats dina titus susie lee and
stephen horsford supported the
impeachment in the house
nevada's lone republican congressman
mark amadeu voted against it
congressman horsford says he wants to go
even further
to be clear this doesn't stop with
donald trump
there are 121 members of congress
who also participated some of them it it
as more information is becoming more
available that may actually have
facilitated
the insurrection so they need to be held
accountable they need to be expelled
and removed uh from office we have heads
of agencies that need to be held
accountable any individual from the
president
to an agency to a member of congress who
is involved in inciting insurrection
against the united states must be held
accountable
president donald trump the only
president in american history to be
impeached
twice and to talk about that and where
we go from here we're joined by our
washington correspondent alexander limon
alex
let's get right into things what are the
chances the senate takes up the
impeachment trial before
the president leaves office well that's
not going to happen
senator mitch mcconnell already
announced that he will not be calling
the senate back from rhesus to begin an
impeachment trial immediately
so that means that likely it will happen
after joe biden
is inaugurated so the purpose of that
would be to try to prevent president
trump from running for office again in
the future
if he is convicted now the timing and
logistics of olivei is going to be
pretty tricky because
obviously the new president joe biden is
going to try to be getting his agenda
off the ground trying to
get uh cabinet members confirmed through
the senate maybe even trying to pass
a coveted release bill so we've actually
heard from joe biden on this topic and
he said
he's had conversations with the top
senators to try to figure out if they
can essentially
divide their days in half and deal with
his legislative agenda for half the day
and then deal with the senate
impeachment trial of president trump for
the other half of the day
so that's a lot to take on so we likely
have you know
some pretty busy days and weeks ahead of
us here on capitol hill
it seems as though there might still be
up in the air if there's going to be an
appetite to continue with this process
when
uh president biden takes office next
week as you mentioned there's a lot on
his agenda as well
any gauging on whether the appetite will
sustain itself into the next
administration
yeah there's some mixed reaction
obviously uh republicans
are among those who are saying this is
unnecessary he will no longer be in the
white house
some democrats as well wonder if it is
the wisest path
to move forward but on the other hand we
are also hearing from
top democrats who say there needs to be
some sort of consequence because
obviously now president trump has been
impeached for
inciting a riot in which members of the
public we now know were trying to
assassinate some of the top members of
congress so they say they can't just let
that slide and they do feel that a
senate impeachment trial to try to
convict the president does still
need to happen and that was alexander
limon from washington d.c as we
mentioned
mark amaday nevada's only no vote
against the article of impeachment
in a statement the republican said the
article of impeachment is not strongly
drafted due primarily to an objective
which is he says the ends justify the
means the fledgling investigation he
says is already verifying that those who
led the perpetrators
were hardly driven to action within an
hour of the right beginning
i vote no congresswoman dina titus says
she was worried that violence in the
capital could spread all the way here to
nevada
i do worry about it because people are
encouraged to take action in their own
hands and we are a government of laws
and that's what we should follow now
when
when we saw people storming the capital
uh who would have
ever imagined that to be the case and we
have a constitutional duty i swore when
i was
elected to protect the constitution and
the government and
and that's not what happened last
wednesday and one of the reasons trump
needs to go that he's
still a danger is that he could pardon
all these people and he controls the
nuclear button we'll have more on the
inauguration and the security steps
being taken in washington
later in the program now to the state
legislature metro police are
recommending charges against a now
formal former nevada assemblyman over a
campaign finance issue
and for not living in his district this
week assemblyman alex ascepha resigned
while facing those charges
the democrat represented district 42
that's essentially spring valley
he's also thought to be the first
ethiopian american elected to public
office here in the u.s
this week metro police told the i-team
they recommended the district attorney
charge asepha with two dozen
counts they're related to his not living
in his district
misusing campaign funds burglary and
theft
prosecutors though have not filed the
charges just yet
a second seat in the legislature also
needs to be filled but for a very
different reason
state senator ivana kinsella is
resigning to join the biden
administration
cancella is joining the u.s department
of health and human services
the democrat was a senior advisor to the
biden campaign during the election
before joining the state senate she was
the political director for the culinary
union
cancella represented district 10 that
includes mccarran airport
and portions of the las vegas strip both
replacements will be picked by the clark
county commission the candidates will
have to apply they have to live in the
district obviously and be democrats
the legislative session starts february
1st
clark county school students are going
to stay largely in distance learning
however this week ccsd trustees took
small steps towards reopening schools
superintendent dr jesus jarrah and the
trustees will allow the return of small
groups
on a voluntary basis sasha loftis
explains what happened in this week's
board meeting
the clark county school district is
taking small steps
towards reopening schools i am worried
about their education i feel like
they're getting cheated
it's a decision many parents call long
overdue
after months of distance learning
struggles and trustees
previous moves to delay any action the
younger kids just
it's really hard not having that
teacher or that assistant there just to
keep them on track
two votes were passed during thursday's
regular board meeting
the first approved an agreement with the
clark county education association
to lay groundwork for an eventual k
through third grade hybrid transition
i believe that we should really focus on
a plan let's get some sort of plan in
place
and then continue working on distance
learning
the second which was unanimous will
allow principals to bring students who
need
extra support back to campus in small
groups on a limited basis
because there's no such thing as a
comprehensive plan and i think that we
all know that being adults
that said we need i think we need hope
there's still no word on a timeline but
families tell us
they want to see concrete change so
their kids
can succeed i think that you're doing
them a huge injustice
by the not being to get an education
at school that was sasha loftus
reporting
trustees also heard a report seeing 90
percent of ccsd schools assigned
more failing grades this year than last
year 2019-2020
it's a key reason that principals are
being allowed to bring struggling
students
back to campus for help coming up next
here on politics now are elected
officials jumping the line the itunes
vanessa murphy looks into who
is and who is not getting the covet
vaccine in nevada
plus planning a safe inauguration
welcome back
to politics now it is a lingering
question as nevada
and the nation fight the coronavirus
when can people get the vaccine
well this week plants changed the new
plan outlined by governor steve
sissellac divides nevadans into two
lanes
frontline workers and the general public
when you get the vaccine depends on
which one of those two groups you're in
front line workers are getting the
vaccine now they'll be able to go into
two large vaccination centers that are
opening this week and they're all by
appointment
people 70 years of age and older can
also sign up for an appointment
to get a vaccine at that location if
you're in the general population right
now
in that lane and you're under the age of
70 you're going to get a vaccine from
your pharmacy
health officials say once a vial is open
they really have to use it
and some businesses with a lot of front
line workers are able to vaccinate all
their employees
i think one really important concept to
understand
is that the storage and handling of the
vaccine is
incredibly difficult and challenging and
after a vial is punctured
there's a very short window to
essentially use that
those doses within the vial before they
expire essentially
for now people can fill out a vaccine
interest form that'll notify them when
they can get that vaccine
we have a link to the form and where you
can sign up for an appointment if you're
a front line worker
or you're over the age of 70 everything
you need is at eightnewsnow.com
elected officials in some cities are
also getting the vaccine
even if the cdc has them at a lower
priority
the itunes vanessa murphy has that story
some viewers contacted us to say
something doesn't seem quite right about
how the city of henderson is handling
the vaccine
the concern is whether elected officials
jumped the line
coronavirus vaccines that are being
distributed throughout
the united states right now including
right here in henderson
some city of henderson employees
including elected officials could get
vaccinated
as early as january 4th alongside
front-line workers like
firefighters and police a spokeswoman
tells the i-team elected officials are
critical to city operations but
according to the southern nevada health
district
public officials were in tier two behind
front line workers not alongside them in
the state's new vaccination plan
released monday
the health district says public
officials still fall
in the second group there's confusion to
say the least
according to the cdc the state is far
behind in vaccinating nevadans
the i team asked the governor about this
why
is this since we have known that we
would need a vaccination plan and why
has it taken so long
to come up with this newer playbook well
it hasn't taken
so long vanessa really come up with it
you know we've been planning this for a
long time we did not have the resources
the i-team also reached out to other
cities in southern nevada and
clark county to find out where public
officials fall in their vaccination
plans
here's what they told us in clark county
umc directly received vaccine doses for
health care workers and first responders
the county is not administering the
vaccine
employees and elected officials are
expected to follow guidelines
the city of las vegas points to the
health district as the lead
and the vaccine is being rolled out to
first responders like hospital staff
fire and law enforcement in north las
vegas
firefighters emt's police officers and
corrections staff were vaccinated first
critical infrastructure employees like
elected officials
can get vaccinated starting wednesday
boulder city
confirms no council members have
received the vaccine through the city at
this point
mayor kiernan mcmanus saying quote i
plan to follow the recommendations for
vaccination based on my age
without regard to my position as mayor
that would place me
in tier four end quote a different
approach
from the city of henderson deeply we
appreciate the incredible strength and
spirit that you've shown
during this unparalleled year in a
follow-up email a spokeswoman for the
city of henderson
insists the mayor and city council fall
within tier one
because they make crucial decisions for
the city
you can read more of her response at
eight newsnow dot com
vanessa murphy eight news now in another
follow-up email the city of henderson
spokesperson
insisted that the mayor and council fall
within tier one as vanessa just
mentioned
and she also mentioned that the city has
returned vials it hasn't used to the
health district and again you can find
more details at eightnewsnow.com
a man both loved and hated coming up on
politics now we're going to take a look
at the life of casino magnate sheldon
adelson
after he passed away earlier this week
and protecting the next president the
extra security measures being taken
to keep inauguration day safe you're
watching
politics now
the inauguration of president-elect joe
biden is next week
officials in washington are stepping up
security after the capitol hill riot
january 6th
the fbi is warning police departments
nationwide need to be ready for armed
protests at their capitol buildings on
wednesday
in nevada law enforcement agencies are
not identifying what specific
precautions will be taken
here meanwhile metro police are
investigating if any officers
took part in last week's capitol hill
riot sheriff joe lombardo says if they
did
they could lose their job we're working
hand in hand with the fbi
and we're going through all the videos
and relying on people to call in if they
know
and we'll do an intensive follow-up if
in fact we do identify somebody
right now metro police tells us they
have no evidence that any of its
officers
were inside the capitol henderson and
north las vegas police departments both
say they were not aware of any officers
that also took part in those capitol
hill riots
so what precautions are being taken in
washington d.c
our d.c bureau's raquel martin tells us
the unprecedented security measures
ahead of the inauguration
joseph robinette biden jr less than a
week before joe biden is sworn in as the
next president
the nation's capital has transformed
from a tourist attraction
to a military zone i'm very appreciative
ohio democratic senator sherrod brown
who will attend next week's ceremony
says he welcomes extra security
following last week's deadly
insurrection
i have concerns that a number of these
these mobsters these violent far
right-wing
white supremacists will come back with
guns
local and federal law enforcement
including the secret service have
already shut down nearby streets
and the pentagons deployed thousands of
national guardsmen
by inauguration day 20 thousand troops
will occupy the area
many armed thursday vice president pence
visited fema headquarters to be briefed
on inauguration day security
the american people deserve
a safe inauguration in wednesday night
president trump delivered his most
forceful statement to date against
violence
mob violence goes against everything i
believe in
and everything our movement stands for
i'm not afraid of taking you
outside president-elect biden says his
team is also receiving security
briefings
we need to go back and review everything
in the meantime republicans and
democrats
are demanding an investigation to
prevent future domestic attacks
it's unclear exactly when military
troops will leave the nation's capital
but by inauguration day there will be
more military troops in washington d.c
than currently in iraq and afghanistan
combined
for now in washington raquel martin back
to you
and we'll of course cover inauguration
day right here on channel eight our
coverage begins at five o'clock on
inauguration day morning
and will last throughout the day a man
both loved
and hated coming up next we're going to
take a look at the life of casino magnet
sheldon adelson
casino czar sheldon adelson passed away
this week
he arrived in las vegas back in the
1980s running what was at the time
our largest convention adelson became
one of the world's richest men
a major player in las vegas a
philanthropist and a huge
republican donor joe moeller looks back
at adelson's legacy
just two things in life billionaire las
vegas casino mogul sheldon adelson
passed away monday
while born in boston in 1933 a good
portion of his life was las vegas
in the late 80s he purchased the sands
hotel and casino which eventually was
replaced by the venetian
then he built the palazzo las vegas
sands also expanded with several resorts
in asia
our city and our state
is such such a better place
because of sheldon adelson steve hill
ceo of the las vegas convention and
visitors authority recognized adelson's
impact
he had a tremendous influence on what we
do
on the meetings and convention industry
adelson also helped bring the state's
first nfl team to las vegas it's
important to point out
that mr allison was was really the
driving force behind the legion stadium
the billionaire was a veteran and a
major financial contributor to the
republican party and
president trump adelson and his wife
miriam were well-known philanthropists
donating millions to anti-drug and
jewish organizations
there are many many things that mr
adelson and dr alderson
have been involved in their philanthropy
journey in
medical breakthrough in the connection
between the jewish people
all around the continuity of the jewish
people
all around the world joe muller 8 news
now
adelson was buried at the mount of
olives in jerusalem friday morning
we have a lot more on sheldon adelson in
his life here in las vegas on eight
newsnow dot com
ron futrell looks at his role in
bringing the las vegas raiders here and
building a legion stadium
and george knapp uses his own interviews
with sheldon adelson
to examine his legacy adelson was also
an extremely influential player in the
republican
political world among the things he
pushed for and accomplished
adelson became the largest known
individual donor in electoral history
in two thousand twelve he spent ninety
million dollars on republicans in that
presidential race
the money mostly went through super pacs
essentially adelson was the main backer
of the republican jewish coalition
the group helped expand the jewish
republican voting base during that time
they also had their yearly meeting at
the venetian he was also extremely
influential in getting the u.s embassy
in israel moved to jerusalem
and of course he was the owner of the
local newspaper the las vegas
review journal the first major paper to
endorse then candidate donald trump for
president of the united states
here's what to watch this week governor
steve sisselak will air his state of the
speech at the state of the state address
six o'clock on tuesday the 19th the
republican rebuttal will be done by
assembly republican
leader dr robin titus we're going to
carry both live right here on channel 8.
the inauguration of president joe biden
is on tuesday we're going to watch that
as well
our wednesday i beg your pardon it's
also uh on capitol hill
in carson city we're going to keep an
eye on the security there law
enforcement says they do expect armed
protests nationwide
on inauguration day thank you very much
for watching us here on politics now
you can stay up to date on all the
political news online at 8newsnow.com
we're back with you every saturday stay
safe and have a good rest of your
[Music]
weekend
[Music]
[Music]
you